nfts have reached a new low what is an
nft god damn it do i really have to
answer this i don't even
it's a digital proof of ownership how
[ __ ] hard is it to understand it's a
token that cannot be copied or replaced
but why can't i just right click and
save on it
nft is a decentralized way for artists
to not just earn money of their work but
also an extra percentage any time the
artwork sells again it's a nfts is about
supporting artists i swear
it's about the technology that's what i
care about not the money
anyway nfts you probably heard about
whatever i'm personally pretty
indifferent to it i think it's a cool
idea has a ton of potential and it's
actually really interesting except that
it's not
i think ever since people sold all his
art for uh one nft for 69 million
everyone just went
oh
well
i can make jpegs
i'm an artist now it's all about the
money now they it's not about the artist
and i think that's why nfts has gotten
such a bad ret you got people like jake
paul nft drop baby who wouldn't want
that i he just loves the art he loves
the technology just to be fair here
obviously with anything there's going to
be a few stinkers here and there that
doesn't mean it's all bad but it doesn't
look good
now a bunch of companies are trying to
get in on the trend we got ubisoft doing
their skins in game that's awesome as an
nft that's so cool ubisoft you're such a
cool company everyone loves you
who wouldn't want to buy that
pepsi is doing nfts i don't know why
they're supposed to sell sodas last time
i checked but okay
and for those of you who are wondering
yes there is a pewdiepie nft i of course
had nothing to do with this
it's up for 4 million how
it's so uncanny it it looks just like me
i
i honestly i get it jesus christ dude uh
but a few days ago we hit peak nft with
keanu reeves being asked about the
matrix nft collection it's got them
beautiful i know everyone thinks kiana
reeves is like reddit tear oh he's so
bad everyone just loves it he's a
beautiful man i don't care what anyone
says and look at this response see the
matrix nft thing that they did for
resurrections just a couple days ago
they know
they made uh nfts for the new movie and
there were like 100 000 of them and the
site broke like in the first few hours
because there were over 300 000 people
in the queue trying to buy these nfts
for 50
um
and so like when you think about the
concept of digital scarcity and things
that are
you know that can't be copied that are
easily reproduced
well
but they're not the same right
what is that laughs keanu reeves in that
moment destroyed nfts
[Music]
hold up i gotta just right click save on
that oh wait oh god damn beautiful god
bless you killing him and uh it's also
interesting his response uh the
interviewer if you listen version of you
i wonder what uh do we get a cut of that
oh no i don't actually i don't think
we're in them they probably they're
easily reproduced but they're not the
same right it's not a fake version of
you keanu goes actually that wasn't us
do we get a cut of that oh no i don't
actually i don't think we're in them
but nfts is about supporting the artist
obviously come on it's about the
technology it's really cool there's
nothing uh artists don't earn commission
as uh right now that doesn't exist at
all
don't tell anyone okay
and if t bros is gonna be real mad
listen i think it's still cool i just
think people are doing lame with it
that's my whole point with this just to
double down on this keanu reeves is a
beautiful man i love his response on
facebook's metaverse which is supposed
to be this like virtual world that
facebook is creating and i have the
exact same opinion i'm like okay cool
can
mark zuckerberg not be the one doing
that
i don't want to be in his virtual world
and this is what kiana reeves says
be like invented by
facebook and you're not a fan
no but just the concept of metaverse is
like way older than right
okay yeah it's like a way older and so
for that moment to get to
i'm just like come on man
come on man i don't know if this is his
quote i couldn't find it but i just
think it's a good quote in general that
the purpose of art is to be experienced
not owned a bunch of bros mistaken art
for investment doesn't change that and i
could go on you know there was the
monkey nfts that you've seen probably
there was a bunch of stinkers about them
online for all kinds of reasons mainly
because they're really ugly i don't
understand why anyone would want to own
this but people did
someone accidentally sold theirs for 3
000 because they missed a few decimal
points there they're supposed to sell it
for 300 000
oh i can guarantee you that does not
happen in the art world right uh someone
also got their three nfts hacked which
is also i mean great fantastic taking a
screenshot on a of an nft is a digital
version of posing in front of someone
else's lamborghini you paid one
quadrillion dollars for a jpeg
cope uh i wanted to be known that
anytime i look at an nft i delete it
right off my retina okay
i don't even remember it i don't
remember a single nft in a lot of ways
the whole screenshotting meme is as
cringy as the nft meme in itself like
you clearly don't forget it if you think
screenshotting in nft is the funniest
thing you've ever seen but yesterday or
a few days ago we reached peak
nft the lowest i have ever seen and uh
it just kind of perfectly summarizes
everything bad about nfts which is the
fact that stanley
came back from the dead because he was
just so passionate about supporting
artists
that he's had to tell us all about his
new nft drop baby how is this real i
thought he was hacked at the at the at
first glance but it turns out he's not i
guess because it's still up there
championing diversity to embracing new
tech so stan lee liked new tank
therefore it's okay for us to
promote his image after he died to cash
in as much as possible right am i really
going to defile this grade for money of
course i am well done mr krabs he's the
one behind this drop this epic drop
their website is called beyond life club
that's sinking i don't know how i feel i
don't like them i don't like it i don't
like it at all you know it's not like
stan lee was working on this before he
died and his last will was
make the nft drop as lit as possible you
know this is just someone thinking how
can we cash in on this and sell stan
lee's image there you go that's so cool
who
i guess the one annoys me about it too
is that people are obviously gonna buy
it right which is so so annoying i hate
it no but it's honoring his birthday
honoring what would have been stanley's
birthday that's why not we're not trying
to cash in dreaming
this is so effing disrespectful to stan
lee what the hell is this yeah one of
the most beloved figures as has become
an actual a very fungible token i would
say
apparently for people that don't care
i hate it anyway like i said i think
there's cool stuff to be done with nfts
this is that no one's doing it this is
people that don't care they're just
trying to cash in and therefore it's
lame and until that changes it's lame
nft
gets a four
but you know a great way to earn money
is subscribing to this channel because
you could
win a billion dollars
subscribe now subscribe and like and
comment and you could
it's not a scam